[Music]
what was that
leave the drugs need the guns and walk
away where's Batman
[Music]
[ __ ] hey everybody its charlie we got to
talk all about Titans and Batman and how
they're dealing with the character in
the Robin backstory I'm doing a new
round of that DC streaming service
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video so the interesting thing about
the way they tell his origin story at
least in the first episode and
referenced Batman is through the Raven
character right now she has the
unconscious ability to accidentally see
into people's minds and look at their
memories she'll be better at it later in
the series so that she'll actually be
able to scan people's memories actively
if she needs to get information from
them for right now she has no idea
what's going on with the Church of blood
with Trigon with the terror of Trigon
storyline she's just a teenager in
school with a bunch of people coming
after her for reasons that she doesn't
understand only there's this darkness
inside her in the shadow self that you
see the demon form Raven when she goes
full-blown crazy isn't exactly something
that she can control she talks to it a
little bit we'll talk about that in
future episodes as we get more of those
scenes but because this is the first
episode that's the reason why you get
that flying Grayson's flashback they
start at the beginning of his origin
story the accident that wasn't quite an
accident we believe that your parents
may have been murdered I don't think
it's necessarily going to be the biggest
storyline during season one but there's
still the idea that it's kind of
unresolved maybe they'll pick back up
with it later in the series
both of these scenes are happening in
Detroit that's where Robin has been this
whole time they say that he's been on
the DL for the past year or so
meaning that he hasn't put on his suit
in the past year now obviously it takes
a little while to become a detective so
maybe he hasn't been with Batman for a
little bit longer than that but it's
still relatively fresh in his mind the
thing about the briefcase yeah it looks
really cool it's just a bit of a teaser
for things to come he has a lot more
gadgets that he's taken with him since
he left Batman and he's still in
communication with Alfred it's just that
as of episode 3 he has not physically
spoken to Bruce Wayne but Bruce Wayne
continues to appear in a lot of scenes
like this and I'm feeling that we're
working our way up to an actual Batman
reveal because here in the circus tent
he puts his hand on Robins shoulder and
says I want to help you and then you
hear his voice with each episode you get
a little bit more and more of Bruce
Wayne until you see him from the front
then you see him actually speak to
Robins
through a doorway so I haven't seen the
last couple of episodes so I can't
really say what they do with the
character then but because this is all
about Robins arc and him becoming
Nightwing along with the Raven and the
Trigon stuff it just seems like by the
end of the season he's not gonna blame
Batman for all the darkness within him
that he's trying to deal with so that's
a little bit of what's going on when he
drops the f-bomb because the setup for
these criminals that you don't
necessarily get in this clip is that
he's been investigating them for a while
they abused children so he's really
pissed off about that in the way he
takes them down super hardcore is meant
to be a mirror of the brutal way that
Batman takes them down in the context of
this series the actor that plays Robin
said that in his mind this version of
Batman kills people or has killed people
in the past and that's one of the big
reasons why he left is because he feel
like he was working his way up to that
too so this is him on the edge of
darkness so you're still getting a
little bit of the Batman version of
Robin by the end of the series he says
his arc is all about finding a better
way to be a superhero that's not quite
so brutal so that's all part of him
becoming Nightwing on the show adopting
a new identity to go with his new ethos
in his new modus operandi but if you're
really upset with a series because they
make their Batman a killer that's not
the producers of the writers doing that
that's just the actor saying that he
feels like their version of Batman in
their backstory did that it's just one
of those situations where you have young
people blaming older people for a lot of
their problems instead of dealing with
them themselves a lot of the saltiness
that he has for Bruce Wayne in the way
that he was raised peppers his
relationship with the Raven character
early on like he's very reluctant to
take her on
but eventually he sees that she needs
him so much in his under so much threat
that he just has to get his [ __ ]
together
where are we going
somewhere safe but the other cool thing
about this is that it gives you a look
at his fighting style so I haven't
talked a whole lot about the fight
scenes they do have some really badass
fight scenes definitely on par with some
of arrows best arrow does tend to have
some of the best DCTV fight choreography
if you guys didn't know arrow episode 1
is dropping Monday night it's a Monday
night show now it's not on Wednesday
nights anymore but you'll see my video
when I post it so no worries Oliver in
prison just beating the crap out of
people for the first half of the season
I don't even talk too much about Beast
Boy I'll probably do some more videos
about him in the future there's a really
good moment with him at the end of
episode 1 it shows you his
transformation ability just to give you
a preview of things to come
the way the actor explained him is that
just like Raven like his abilities will
evolve he'll eventually be green all the
time but I think what they're trying to
tell you with this scene here with him
stealing the video games that he's
pulling a fast one on the security guard
just having a little bit of fun is that
he will bring a little bit of the
lighter tone to the series and be a
version of the character that you're
familiar with have you been a big fan of
him for a long time
once you have a chance to watch Titans
everybody let me know what you think of
the first episode they're releasing
weekly everybody just keep your eyes
peeled for when they drop on Netflix if
you live outside the United States if
you're inside the United States you get
episodes on that DC streaming service so
what'll happen is is I'll name a
giveaway winner when I post new DC
there's an Avengers for comic-con panel
where Chris Evans talks about his very
last scene that he filmed as Captain
America in his very last words of
dialogue so if I work quickly enough I
can post that later tonight if not I'll
just post it tomorrow no worries while
you wait for everything click here for
my Titans review and click here for that
new Spider Man far from home teaser
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight